welcome to this video playing rousset
eyes black and this is slovenia right
yes okay um yeah playing yourself does
not look like playing at the moment
somehow no movers are coming here okay
now we have one and I had just played
this sorry dear I've let's let's apply
this solid fianchetto okay seems dark
white is going forth no you almost Kings
Indian attack but with the night only
two yeah one of those setups that
certainly can be played not very young
very dangerous or anything but of course
playable yeah what should I do b5 before
maybe gaining space on the queenside
yeah I want to have be for Bishop a six
in we are taking this song this is some
this is definitely a weakness m desai
this pond with out the bishop on my left
80 87 now maybe this wasn't a great idea
this quick b5 looks really a bit
problematic here this porn shoot a six
and deform maybe like d4 Knight f5 k is
playing d for himself okay yeah not very
happy this not very happy about this oik
is taking with the part now thats it's
helpful I was more worried about the
piece I coming to deform
now of course he's got a huge space
advantage here I hope the position is
solid enough should I push a 5-2 block
now maybe the only issue after f-5e
cakes and the piece takes theoretically
speaking that the e porn might be weak
but he's miles away from putting any
pressure on this porn so it's not
happening it was really a purely
defensive in him that getting some space
on the King side and if he gets in I g3
and f5 himself this look Sam should be
avoided
and I'm ahead on the clock for once not
happening often yeah f5 I'm still still
happening probably
maybe you can play night you five year
attacking you six yeah my notes
especially the seven night this is not
really great okay maybe ever really h5
maybe
maybe h5
I want some sort of play a be night
before as my dear now maybe you can just
take worth the Queen play this position
I'm really not sure that this is doing
much but I elect counterplay really yeah
be sure to d3 maybe but what is this
doing them up clear 93 you should go
back here pawn takes if I take with the
noisy my player 5 Wow very difficult the
idea behind this move was 93 to attack
f1 f2 good news is he's really slow like
slower than even I am tick tick with the
night as f5 coming
taking with the point is also looking
totally ridiculous okay ready to take
with this now back to a second or taking
maybe taking Jack why that's difficult I
don't think I'm in terrible shape I have
stole a number of defensive pieces here
we are like Queen Queen age 6 for
instance m1 choir Queen Queen h5 may be
really coming mighty 69 f7 also
undertaking and twin to h5 ok night is
six
time morning if a five is also hanging
hey don't see move that's really
dangerous attack how more dangerous than
I believed I thought I have many defense
of pieces but especially the g5 night is
obviously very strong take here take one
III or something I'm not worried about
the exchange really but all pieces are
coming here right h5 is like Queen age
five now
maybe I can confuse them Knight takes
Queen Texas III hanging hook these three
2697 Queen III check is winning for
black I think I'm winning here on time
and maybe on position and i would
definitely outside position why distance
and time I was probably downright lost
for me i had was difficult this position
i thought i should be ok but I maybe I
may be played it to miss plated totally
jerem I probably defend it very poorly
here beginning with the smooth I wanted
some sort of play but here I mean okay
the computer wants to play the same but
it's certainly not a good position Queen
d6 now with a wide advantage not quite
simply has some so many pieces near the
king yeah after 95 white is winning a
plus 2 played this is how queen age 5 is
very strong I could have played night x
f5 immediately with a big advantage ok
but this is this is very very strong
just night f7 is the threat I wanted to
play Queen f6 but I mean not not
I can just go here this is a disaster
totally totally losing him again night a
queen g four winds yeah yeah a night
only six huh so this is this is winning
provide after this night f5 is winning
yeah that wasn't lucky winner we really
really had a devastating attack and um
it was it was not easy to defend but I
really should have done a better job
here okay thanks for watching